the birth of her first child but
Michelle didn't know at the time that in
just a few days doctors would give her
infected blood leaving a deadly virus
swimming inside of her I didn't know
then at that time at the age of 22 that
I'd been given a death sentence for
committing no crimes because at the end
of 2015
I found out by chance that in fact the
blood that was there to saved my life
contained hepatitis C Michelle's fight
isn't over even if the inquiry into the
infected blood Scandal is
it is described as the worst treatment
disaster in the history of the NHS
thousands of people were infected with
HIV and hepatitis C many died 500 of
them since the start of this inquiry
among the dead 74 schoolmates of Richard
Warwick infected when the boarding
school they attended ran experimental
treatment on students without informed
consent it's just devastating
and the fact that the college was used
to run trials on the boys using
different types of medication
they were effectively purposefully
infected
evidence has been heard for four and a
half years sometimes from prominent
politicians
but many key Witnesses have been missing
either died or too unwell to attend an
inquiry taking place decades after the
event I have written to the paymaster
general
to inform him of my intention to make a
further interim report about the
framework for compensation
I anticipate
that I'll be in a position to do so
before Easter
if not earlier
for long time campaigners like Colette
this pressure on the government is key
for many this has been cathartic for me
it is a relief to have got to the point
now where all that evidence and the
allegations that we presented to the
police to the government to the doctors
the politicians has been haired at this
inquiry and I hope from that that sir
Brian can only reach one possible
conclusion the Chairman's report is due
to be published in the Autumn Saudia
Chaudhary Sky News at the infected blood
inquiry in London